c'est la renaissance d'une auberge fermé
en 1965 l'auberge des trois hameaux à
choisel était devenu une maison
d'habitation
puis la commune a décidé de la racheter
en 2017
l'inauguration a eu lieu en présence de
nombreux élus dont gérard larcher
président du sénat qui a apporté son
soutien à ce projet c'est le fruit de la
volonté d'abord d'une équipe municipale
et aussi de la chef d'entreprise qui a
eu le courage de s'engager et les temps
ne sont pas faciles pour cet engagement
c'est aussi le fruit du soutien du
département de la région ils ont aidé à
concevoir à financer accompagner ce
projet d'auberge c'est une choisel yen
qui a été choisie pour être la gérante
de l'établissement
après plusieurs candidatures avec une
salle de 80 m² 50 couverts l'auberge des
trois hameaux propose une cuisine
traditionnelle française
plus qu'un simple restaurant cet
établissement est un lieu de passage
on a mis en place un relais colis ou on
va accueillir les jeunes choisis lien le
mercredi midi à l'auberge à manger on
est sur la kz2 l'avait losséni donc on
va accueillir des cyclistes on va
accueillir des randonneurs voilà c'est
un endroit un peu à la croisée de
plusieurs chemins seul commerce de
choisel un million d'euros a été investi
pour concrétiser ce projet de rénovation
c'est quand même un travail de plus de
trois années déjà d'avoir un lieu de
convivialité d'accueil sur choisel est
aussi d'activités économiques qui
éclaterait emploi ce lieu accueillera
aussi un gîte à laitages pour six
personnes